tokens with us in Washington high table
and how are you hi doing good you better
than I deserve how can I help
well an honor to speak with you hey so
I've got a question and my question is
related towards credit cards my wife
tends to disagree with me when I keep
preaching to her that credit cards
aren't appropriate and she believes that
they are and I can't explain them to her
because the math formula is not posted
and there isn't a math formula for it so
I can't even explain the math so I'm
kind of curious how to explain a Matt
somehow in math and in telling her that
the credit card to generate a credit
score is pointless because of the amount
of money that it costs you and she seems
to think that credit cards to build a
credit score won't cost you anything if
you pay it off everyone okay
well here's the thing you can do okay
lay down two $100 bills in front of you
and lay down a piece of plastic a credit
card in front of you when you do that in
your mind right now you can see it in
your mind can't you I can see I can see
it in my head right now when I did that
okay I'm going to picture that those two
$100 bills are more emotional than that
piece of plastic would you agree
absolutely and what happens is and
there's tons of research that shows this
that when you spend the cash the laying
down a $100 bill at dinner laying down a
$100 bill at the grocery store laying
down a $200 at the electronics store or
whatever it is to buy a shirt I don't
care what it is when you lay down cash
it activates the pain centers of your
brain and people who spend plastic have
a tendency to spend a good deal more
than you do with cash for that reason
because you don't feel it when you spend
on an average person purchase it's a
twelve to twenty eight percent more
or that you'll spend so and that's the
average purchase now the more expensive
the item is the more you have attendants
are the less you have a tendency to
overspend the cheaper the item is the
more you let me give you an example if
you put a vending machine in a hotel
lobby and it takes credit cards it
increases the sales on the vending
machine if it takes credit cards credit
card users spend a hundred and seventy
eight percent more so they buy a coke
and a chips right they double their
purchases by coca chips and a candy bar
or they buy one for somebody standing
there with them because they're using
the credit card you don't feel it now
you know when you're buying something
super expensive you know you're spending
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
dollars it won't apply won't be as big a
percentage but you still don't register
the expenditure and you have a tendency
to buy things you wouldn't buy and to
spend more particularly when you're
doing a target run a Walmart run a
Costco or Sam's Run you're going to spin
more when you use plastic than when you
use real money and so you know that's
the math part of it now the other thing
is this it's kind of a ludicrous idea to
say I want to go into debt why so that I
can get the opportunity to go into debt
said no wealthy said no wealthy person
ever yes what what about homes though
and that's the only reason I know you
don't have a credit score to get a home
well she's saying that limits your
opportunity you're all know it doesn't
she doesn't know what she's talking
about so where where can I find
information to kind of assist in that
area
Churchill mortgage our advertiser will
show you how to get a home with
absolutely no credit score if you have a
zero credit score and you can get a
mortgage you can get a mortgage that is
exactly the same interest rate as if you
have a seven hundred credit score
it's called manual underwriting they
actually have to check out and see that
you have a job and that you have the
money for the down payment and they have
to do a little bit more work but they
can get you that mortgage and that's one
of the reasons we endorse them now some
mortgage companies don't know how to do
that
but that can be done and so this is
mythology the truth is is that she has
other reasons for wanting to use the
credit card it gives her freedom from
having to report to you and be
accountable it gives her freedom to buy
things on impulse that she doesn't have
to think about and she doesn't like the
restrictions of the boundaries of
putting together an actual plan and
sticking to it that's the real reason
but all of these other things are
intellectual rationalizations me well we
do pretty good
all right budget we have a break broke
our budget and we actually are out of
debt we have no debt that's good we have
our emergency fund and we're saving for
our baby right now good that's awesome
I'm glad but the typical millionaire
does not run around saying I hope I can
build up airline miles that's not I mean
I've met with millionaires all it for
all my life and coach them all the time
and multi millionaires and they don't
say Dave you know I made all my money
with my air miles
I hope my credit score is good I don't
worry about the credit score just buy
things and that's how they became
millionaires I think it sucked into
these other people's game hey you guys
Rachel Cruz here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right kind of better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you